tank rabatt und neun euro ticket waren
zwar eine schöne sache aber die sorge
vor einem kalten winter vor einer neuen
corona welle und weiteren preis
explosionen sind weit größer und das
vertrauen dass die regierung diese
probleme in den griff bekommt dass die
uns beschützen kann das findet wie die
neuen umfragezahlen im auftrag von bild
sein
die unzufriedenheit mit der aktuellen
regierung und olaf scholz wird im
kanzler so deutlich wie nie zuvor um die
ohren gehauen gerade einmal 29 prozent
der bevölkerung in deutschland halten
laut einer bürgerbefragung des
beamtenbundes dbb den staat noch für
fähig seine aufgaben zu erfüllen
66 prozent halten ihn dagegen mit den
problemen unserer zeit für überfordert
ich bin nicht so viel schutz wie sehen
sie wollte das als neue gesetze ist der
alte war riesengroß und ganzen bin ich
zufrieden aber aktuell was die ukraine
betrifft und die hilfe an die ukraine da
könnte man schon schneller reagieren die
rüben groß und
nur 27 prozent sind derzeit noch
insgesamt mit der arbeit der ampel
koalition zufrieden im märz waren es
immerhin noch 44 prozent eine echte
regierungs klatsche auch die letzten
umfragen im auftrag der bild am sonntag
laut dem meinungstrends kommt die spd
nur noch auf 19 prozent befürwortung und
die fdp auf 8 prozent einzige ausnahme
die grünen sie erreichen 21 prozent dass
es mehr als ihr ergebnis der
bundestagswahl mit knapp 15
prozentpunkten klarer sieger ist aber
die cdu sie erreicht ganze 28 prozent
aber auch dem kanzler selbst steht das
wasser bis zum hals nur noch 18 prozent
der befragten stehen hinter
oppositionsführer friedrich merz kommt
da immerhin auf 19 prozent und mehr als
eine nasenlänge vorne liegt vizekanzler
robert habeck mit satten 25 prozent
mit der arbeit von olaf scholz es
aktuell auch nur noch jeder vierte
befragte zufrieden im märz waren es
immerhin noch 45 prozent
der kanzler im scherbenhaufen muss nun
überzeugt auftreten und zeigen dass er
die wichtigen themen für den
krisenherbst doch noch in den griff
bekommt
[Musik]
also heftiger gegenwind bei solchen
veranstaltungen solchen bürger dialogen
bei denen der kanzler aufgetreten ist
wobei man dazusagen muss dass war vor
allem im osten und da hatten afd und
linke aufgerufen unser reporter michael
engelberg ist jetzt in essen wo der
bundeskanzler ebenfalls zu einem
bürgerdialog eingetroffen ist vor
wenigen minuten michael wie ist die
stimmung im ruhrpott
ja gut am thomas hier aus essen kult
weltkulturerbe zeche zollverein da
befinden wir uns mit dem kanzler also
man muss sagen hier ist tatsächlich
alles entspannt aber man muss auch sagen
dass hier ein sehr sehr großes
polizeiaufgebot ist hier ist eine
hundertschaft hier sind ganz viele leute
vom bka lka und ganz ganz viele
polizisten in zivil man möchte natürlich
auch bilder verhindern die es bei den
anderen tonnen holz gegeben hat also
hier ist tatsächlich hier steht man
vielleicht verspringt einer mit einem
plakat aber die atmosphäre ist hier vor
der veranstaltungs halle sehr sehr
entspannt und auch oben allerdings muss
man sagen dass das natürlich in dieser
zeit vergnügungssteuerpflichtig ihre
veranstaltungen gibt als natürlich mit
dem bürger mit dem wähler direkt in
kontakt zu treten hier ist ja feuer
freien der grill den kanzler hier ist
von von gas pauschalen von strom von
bildungsungerechtigkeit von lehrermangel
ist hier tatsächlich alles möglich und
das wichtige ist hier gibt es keinen
doppelten boden da könne jetzt nicht
noch mal auf reset drücken oder zurück
das was der kanzler hier sagt da passen
die leute natürlich auf wir haben mit
einigen rentnern schon kontakt gehabt
die so ein bisschen auf der zinne sind
dass die in den entlastungs paketen die
jetzt angekündigt worden sind die
gewesen sind tatsächlich nicht so
richtig berücksichtigt worden sind und
der tank rabatt ihr habt es gerade
angesprochen in der sendung der läuft
jetzt aus andere europäische länder
haben den von vornherein tatsächlich
schon verlängert und auch das wird hier
weiterhin thema sein die leute wollen
antworten vom kanzler und keine kann
sprecher michael du kommst ja jeden tag
in nordrhein-westfalen herum jetzt bist
du gerade in essen wie ist denn die
stimmung dort im bevölkerungsreichsten
bundesland im hinblick auf den ganzen
energie presse die sorgen vor einem
kalten winter corona die neue welle die
da also all diese herausforderungen die
die regierung meistern muss
ja also das ruhrgebiet ist er ehrlich
also wir hier im ruhrgebiet wir sagen
das was wir denken und da sind
tatsächlich viele leute maximal
angefressen es kamen die korona krise da
sind viele vergessen worden viele selbst
die über jahre richtig viel verdient
haben hoteliers gastronomen leute die
firmen haben die wissen tatsächlich in
teil nicht mehr wie es weitergehen soll
und auch der kleine in
anführungsstrichen kleine mann ist in
teilen verzweifelt aber es gibt auch
welche die jetzt nicht den abgesang auf
das abendland loben sondern die
tatsächlich auch versuchen aus dem was
gerade da ist das beste zu machen aber
das problem ist es weiß ja keiner was
tatsächlich ende herbst anfangen anfang
winter und anfang kommenden jahres ja
was da für rechnungen ins haus fallen
und es muss tatsächlich jetzt was
passieren
gestern haben wir lange an einer
tankstelle gestanden in niedersachsen
und die leute haben dem
tankstellenbesitzer die hütte eingerannt
sie haben quasi den tankern glühen
lassen und auch da ist die frage warum
kann das nicht einfach verlängert werden
genauso wie das neun euro ticket ich bin
heute morgen mit dem zug von münster
nach osten von münster nach
recklinghausen gefahren und im gegensatz
zu vorgestern war es maximal er also
dass neun euro ticket wurde genutzt das
haben wir auch alle statistiken alle
zahlen gesagt ja und jetzt ist es
einfach schon die da schon wieder
weniger und ich denke dass die leute und
das ist auch das was sie uns gesagt
haben sie wollen einfach eine
verlängerung bestimmter regeln damit sie
ein bisschen land sehen nach corona nach
diesem sommer der für viele gut
verlaufen ist trotzdem auch gut in den
winter zu kommen damit man auch mit
vollgas ins neue jahr starten kann und
vielleicht die sorgen ein wenig
vergessen kann michael engelberg aus
essen wo der bundeskanzler sich erneut
einem bürgerdialog stellt und wir
sprechen uns und 20 uhr wieder
[Musik]